let's go let's go where do we want to go
next let's try the five one two area
code who's calling today from five one
two yeah what's up David this sorry this
is who you're breaking up I'm sorry it's
Freddie Mac I'm in a bad area what's
going on Freddie I got kind of a
two-part question that's okay sure all
right I'll called into the jessamine
Peterson show and I know you didn't show
I watched it yeah um and when I started
proving him wrong because he was naming
democratic policies he didn't know was
put in place by progressive mm-hmm I
told him what hey well it seems like you
like progressive smoting you're like
Republicans you started screaming beta
mail and all this other stuff my
question to you is with guys like you
and Sam cedar it seem like they're
scared of why don't you guys push the
issue to debate them because you're
already right well listen I mean Jesse
Lee Peterson invited me onto his program
last time I was in LA and I did it so I
mean I don't know it's like I I think
I'm doing it I don't know how frequently
I should be debating Jesse Lee Peterson
he's got a relatively small audience and
like I don't know how it's gonna be the
same thing again but I'm not against it
and I have debated him I guess you could
call it a go I'm sorry I'm sorry maybe I
wasn't clear enough and not just him in
particular but I'm talked about people
like Candace Owens oh yeah people you
just named won't debate me so I don't
know Candace Owens we were surprised we
were both offered money by a third party
to do a debate the third party said
she's good to go I said great let's pick
topics and a date and at that point they
said oh you know it's taking a little
longer it's taking a little longer and
then eventually yeah she's not going to
do it and then Dave Rubin I've said any
time I would have him back on this show
or appear on his and just nothing's
happening yet I don't think he's
interested okay one more question about
our reparations okay um at first I was
against reparations and I'm black okay
and when I found out I did research I
found out that slave owners were paid
reparation sorry again you feel like who
is you broke up who was paid
operations the slave owners when slavery
was was abolished you mean yes yeah I
don't know too much about that well what
I'm saying is people try to tell me well
if you didn't go through slavery you
shouldn't get the money for it and I say
go to my uncle died in the accident
and his sons got the money from Lawson
they got to migrate your breathing he
doesn't I I don't know enough about that
to be able to say more than I've already
said your connection is just getting
crazy but your first part was brilliant
and I really appreciate you calling in
all right thank you okay Freddie great
to hear from you